hi i'm terry sienowski and i'm here
in san diego um at the salk institute
i'm also on the faculty at uc san diego
across the street
and i'm going to be telling you
today about a story
to give us some insights into how the
brain
accomplishes working memory
working memory has been studied over
many decades
of recordings for example from both the
prefrontal cortex and the primal cortex
by pat goldman rakeesh and richard
anderson have shown that there are
neurons that are active
during a delay period when a monkey has
to remember a particular location or an
object and this delay period activity
has been of intense interest to modelers
like me
to try to understand how the circuits in
the cortex
could be responsible for this elevated
delay period activity
so the story i'm going to be telling you
about today
is only possible because of the fact of
that there have been
major advances in machine learning over
the last 10 years
which now have been
uh
used uh by
researchers in in not just my lab but uh
throughout throughout the world to try
to illuminate
the complexity of some of the circuits
that are found and some of the functions
that are found in different parts of the
cortex
so uh
going uh first to some data
so this is a data repository
that we took advantage of that's the crc
and so
nsf program
which uh
recorded
single neurons uh spike trains a
prefrontal cortex a darcel lateral
prefrontal cortex of monkeys
during a working memory task so first so
let's go through it
the monkey is uh
first trained to fixate for one second
and then a cue comes up on either the
left or the right side
and then after a delay period of a
second and a half
a another
sample comes up that
could be either on the same side or the
other side
and if it's on the same side the the
monkey uh
is is instructed to
the cat up and if it's on the if it's
not on the same side then uh the monkey
doesn't have to use a cab
so this is a
a wonderful data set from hundreds of
neurons recorded simultaneously
during these different parts of the
delayed matches sample task and we're
going to be analyzing these data along
with data from our model to try to
compare them
so we'll come back to this uh
so
uh if you go back uh you know 20 years
uh the the dominant model for this delay
period activity
was uh
called an attractor
network model
and and this illustrated here it was
known that if you look at the
connectivity pattern of the cortex
that's dominated by recurrent
connectivity between the excitatory
connectivity between the pyramidal cells
located
uh nearby
and and that produces a lot of positive
feedback and then of course there's a
feed-forward inhibition
uh feedback inhibition i'm sorry from
from the pyramidal cells
which helps maintain stability because
otherwise it would just blow up and then
you have inputs coming in that could
activate a subset of the pyramidal cells
so this was uh
this this uh anatomy suggests
that there might be a very simple
uh explanation for the delay period
activity namely that uh you take
advantage of the positive
feedback
to produce activity in a subset of the
pyramidal cells for example if the
inputs activate these yellow neurons
then they would be activated so here's a
pulse coming in
and with the right parameters you can
activate that subset
and that can be maintained in the
absence of an input but if you now give
it a negative pulse that can turn it off
so that will maintain activity in this
upstate
for the subset that have been activated
now there's a couple things that were a
little bit concerning about this class
of models
detractor models
first of all there are dozens and
hundreds of parameters here that you
have to determine depending on the
detailed
uh model of for example if you have
hodgkin-huxley model
neurons then there's hundreds of ion
currents and
time constants that have to be
specified and so you're you're searching
through this very high dimensional
parameter space and of course you know
if you
search long enough you find a set of
parameters that actually gives you this
performance
and um
and there's something unsatisfying about
that because of course you haven't
really searched it completely maybe
there's another model
that uh uses the same components and
maybe even the same connectivity
and how are you going to find it
so that's what i'm going to be focusing
on today taking advantage of some of the
modern tools and techniques for machine
learning
so here's a model
that was developed by robert kim a
graduate student in my lab
and it starts with a
recurrent neural network of a few
hundred units
uh that are connected up initially
randomly
of 80 are excitatory and 20
inhibitory uh which is the
proportions found in in cerebral cortex
uh and
uh they were given inputs
and then there was uh one output so uh
so this in fact uh this this this one if
there's one input that is being uh fed
into all of the neurons and through
weights that are
going to be adjustable if by learning
algorithm
and then uh also
we can see that the output is going to
be
driven and that
output is going to be compared
to the correct output and then on the
basis of error
the the weights in the recurrent network
are to be updated and that's going to
continue until it converges
so that's a typical machine learning
task but the difference here is that
we're going to be doing it with spiking
neurons because traditionally these
reservoir
networks
are using use continuous valued units a
rate code
but real neurons of course
spike at a regular times and you saw in
the
previous slide
recordings from the prefrontal cortex
how irregular that they were
so here is now on
the bottom
an example of of
a trained network that is responding to
the four different conditions
uh so remember that if the
hue and the sample were the same then it
should go up and so that's shown here
but if it's also if they were down which
means that they were on the other side
uh then it should also go up and so
these are the correct
trials and here are the incorrect trials
as to say the ones where you you want to
down
uh response and and that's when they're
uh
opposite
uh the the the queue does not match the
sample and and what you can see here
is that there's a lot of variability
occurring in in the individual neurons
both excitatory inhibitory and
especially uh you know elevated activity
uh
you know during the uh uh the the
the delay period which is uh
in between the two stimuli
and um and so now uh we've we've
created a network uh we don't know how
it works but it's somehow able to
reproduce
both the
uh input output
behavior of the monkey
but also
we have access to the network so we can
go in
and examine it
with greater much greater detail than we
can go into the brain so in the brain we
can record from a few neurons
and and you can uh you know
you can distinguish between the
excitatory inhibitory neurons maybe what
layer they're in but you really can't
access the connectivity the specific
connectivity of those neurons
which is what we can do here we can do
that for every single input
for every trial and and that's what
we're going to do now is dive in and see
if we can figure out
the algorithm that this network has
discovered
so we need some metrics and so here's
one of the important ones that we're
going to use to
both
analyze the
recurrent network model but also compare
it to the recordings and this has to do
with autocorrelation so the first step
is to bin in 50 millisecond intervals
the spikes the number of spikes
for each trial so here's 50 trials and
each dot is a spike and you can see that
and sometimes there's no spike sometimes
there's one spike sometimes there's two
and that is illustrated below with a
gray scale
so we can see there's a lot of
variability and that's what you see uh
in in recordings
and um now we're going to do is to
correlate two time points like for
example uh the first and the second
separated by 50 milliseconds we're going
to average that over the entire
uh one second time course
and and that's going to give us an
autocorrelation value that you can see
up here a little bit of 0.2 and then now
we do that with 100 millisecond delay
and then 150 millisecond delay and so
forth and we get a curve that in which
the autocorrelation is decreasing we can
fit that to an exponential with a time
constant of 177 milliseconds
so that that is a way to understand
something about the persistence of
activity within the recurrent network
because of the valid fact that they're
talking to each other
uh
they will maintain
a memory of something that came in
177 milliseconds earlier
okay so that's uh now something we want
to apply to both the experimental data
and to the model to see whether there is
a similarity so first of all uh upper
left corner let's look at the baseline
firing rate and we can see that both the
uh
in the in the in the monkey cortex and
in our model trained model the average
firing rate is about five hertz which is
uh
varies obviously up and down during the
task but
it's in the right ballpark
similar variance
and now let's let's look at the
autocorrelation of time constants with
the time scale
and first of all the on train network
down here
as you can see
has a very short
memory seven milliseconds
and that's because it it the connections
are random and there's no reason why it
should have
uh recirculated uh
spikes
uh with you know if if there's random
connectivity especially with inhibitory
neurons that are going to be activating
uh to reduce the activity
so
but if you compare that to the train
network you can see that there's a much
bigger spread of time constants
and uh and in particular uh the median
is about 122 milliseconds and that's
comparable to what you see in the data
from the
dorsolateral prefrontal cortex
and if we split this into two uh the the
shorter on the left and the
the longer on the right and then just
plot those the way we did
in the last slide we can see that the
the time the short time constants
average around 68 69 in both the
experimental and model
and similarly for the long time
constants 133 so so this is actually a
very good quantitative comparison so it
means that there's something
that made you know it could it could
have some uh similarity but we we're
gonna need much more evidence in order
to be able to
conclude that
but at least i think we're
we have some
reason to suspect that the network has
learned something about
uh persistence
now
the
uh
you know the penny dropped when we
started looking at the connections
between the input
and the inhibitory neurons
which is not expected we expected that
they would be connected to the
excitatory neurons because that's what
our models
of the tractor models told us that you
know the inputs were to the
excitatory neurons that were going to go
into the upstate
but no no it turns out here that the uh
the the strong connections are to the
inhibitory neurons okay that's that's
interesting
but even more interesting is the fact
that
there are two populations of inhibitory
neurons there is one subpopulation
which received a strong positive input
they were selectively activated
by the
uh input
and and and then the uh there's another
set of inhibitory neurons that were not
and you can see that it was reflected in
the weights
the weights were positive to the uh
first cell population or negative to the
second sub-population so this is telling
us that there's two subpopulations that
have mutual inhibition between them uh
and this is
something that we
confirmed by looking at the detailed
connectivity
so that's that's uh that's that's a clue
and um
and and then we
started manipulating the network and by
the way this is incredibly important uh
something that we can begin to do
actually in experiments we can we can
activate neurons with channel rhodopsin
or we could uh reduce activity with
these uh optical
techniques for manipulating the activity
and so we did that we could either
increase in this case through increasing
the strengths of the connectivity
between the two subpopulations or
decreasing them
and and what you can see here
is that
if you increase
the strengths the both the time scale
and performance actually
increase a little bit but if you
decrease the strength of time scale and
performance drastically
fall suggesting that these uh mutual
reciprocal and inhibition between the
two subpopulations may be critically
important for
the delay
a period of behavior the performance
being able to maintain activity
and and
we
were um
able to uh explore both the connections
between
the sub-populations and also the
connections within the sub-populations
and it turns out that
the connections between the
sub-populations were significantly
stronger
and the numbers were significantly
greater
and uh the
and if you uh look at the
uh task accuracy
uh the task accuracy depended more on
the reciprocal connections than it did
by changing the strengths of the
connections within
the inhibitory subpopulation so so this
is now the you know
the smoking gun
and and it gives rise to a cartoon
shown here about what might be going on
in this network and might be going on in
in the cortex
so here is the
model
now shown here on the left is the input
and as i was telling you if if there's a
an input that is most strongly connected
to one sub population it will turn that
on and this population will turn off the
other so it's a flip flop either this
top sub-population is not or this one
and because of the fact that there's uh
inhibition
between the inhibitory and the
excitatory neurons the one
sub-population that is activated will
turn off
the one
the excitatory population that it's
paired with and the
the disinhibited excitatory neurons you
see on the on the bottom here are
activated so we have during the input we
have a subpopulation of inhibitory
neurons they're activated in another
subpopulation of excitatory neurons that
are activated but there's no as you can
see here there's no direct connection
between these two but it's always
through the inhibitory reciprocal
inhibitory
subpopulations and what happens now is
because of the fact that uh the that
this is stable you can turn off the
input and in fact uh achieve an even
greater firing rate uh which will be
maintained during the delay period
so this is this is the motif now that we
think is responsible
um
and interestingly other groups that have
studied completely different set of
problems having to do with decision
making you know how how do you decide to
do something uh
you know if you have choices
have have come up with a very similar
kind of a reciprocal inhibitory motif
and so what that raises the possibility
is that the very same motif depending on
how it's connected to the output
uh and the excitatory so popular that
the very same motif could be used for
both
uh which would be very economical and
also tell you that uh that there's uh
there's not separate modules for for
decision making and for maintaining
activity that they're one and the same
okay now we'd like to have some more
evidence right that this is actually
going on and so we found it
in trial by trial variability
so if you record
from a
single neuron say during multiple trials
here's five trials
and you just look at the pattern of
spikes across trials uh there's two
possibilities one is that you know we
know that the interval that the firing
times vary from trial to trial for this
case you know uh early and late on
trials one and two but there's only two
spikes
um
and sometimes it's three and sometimes
it's one but there's very low
variability in the total number of
spikes it's the variance is 0.5 and and
and this could be
quantified with something called a panel
factor the the variability in the number
of spikes
now high variability would occur if for
example that same neuron was highly
active on one trial then maybe very
little activated with say one spike or
none
other trials
and so the question is what's the final
factor then
first of all in the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and and here's the
short and the long time scales that we
discussed earlier
and what you can see is that the long
time scales here tend to have
higher much higher phantom factors uh up
up here in this layer six is very high
so that this by the way uh this
particular diagram had a
pano factor of 5.5 so we're we're
dealing with this uh green condition
here in the dark solar preferred cortex
highly significant between these two uh
groups the short ones and the long ones
suggesting it was the long ones that are
really responsible for the behavior
um
and uh and here now are the analysis for
the recurrent neural network and you can
see that there's a similar
excess of long
high fano factors here in the long time
scale group
and and it's also reflected in the
autocorrelations as well and we tested
both and and and it's clear now that
there's a very nice uh
congruence here
uh between
real neurons and the variability in
those neurons uh within the subpop by
the way i should have said this is
within the subpopulation of inhibitory
cells recorded from the directional
lateral prefrontal cortex
and and this recurrent network here as
well so so this is now again this is uh
i think
pointing us in in a direction
which is revealing
something that i think may turn out to
be a real insight
and i have to say it's not my insight
this insight actually came from the
machine learning algorithm right the
machine learning algorithm
get upon this at this particular
network connectivity and by the way we
ran the algorithm many times on many
networks and they always came up with
the same solution so it suggests that in
some ways this may be the
the most direct or simplest way that you
can implement
the
delay period activity
that has to be maintained some pattern
of activity maintained
across time
to be able to solve the task
and and it's i think particularly
interesting that the inhibitory neurons
are involved here because
they have been neglected you know
everybody knows that they're there to
damp activity but you know they
now we know they have many many other
there are many types and they have many
different functions and so this may be
one of them
so we wanted to uh play around with this
in the model it's one of the things you
do with the model by the way it's very
easy to change the strengths and cut
connections and so forth and
very difficult to do that in vivo of
course but this is at least gives us
more insights so here well here's what
we did
uh
we we had we trained up a network we
looked at trials and i've already showed
you here the height of variability in
terms of the number of spikes across
trials and now what we could do is
strengthen or weaken the connections
within the subpopulation
and and what you can see here is that as
you strengthen
those inhibitory reciprocal inhibitory
connections between the uh in the soft
population you can see
that
or between i'm sorry between the two
subpopulations right
there's a reciprocal connectivity
between something you can see that the
uh there's a lot more failures here
which means that the phantom factor has
gone up and that's shown here on the
bottom times that both the phantom
factor goes up with strength it goes
down with reduction reducing the
reciprocal inhibition between the two
subpopulations and the time scale also
plummets uh it goes up and down by a
factor
uh 100 milliseconds here um
so uh so this is
again uh
something that
we
are able now because if you just look at
the connections and so forth you know
it's hard to really understand just from
the connectivity diagram but what's
really going on but now we we were able
to zero in on a particular sub motif
that is
responsible
now just to show you we we uh that this
is uh that was uh we need controls i
mean the question is what if you
manipulate this right so the other uh
connections in the network right
and so here we have connections between
the inhibitory and excitatory
connections
the of and the the excitatory going to
inhibitory and excitatory inhibitory
you can vary those up and down by 30
percent and the phantom factor does not
change it really is
a
strongly affected by the con inhibitory
connections between two subpopulations
and these two subpopulations are really
the ones that are controlling the
excitatory cells that are producing the
output
right so and and by the way this this is
it's a little bit um
maybe even a lot
uh
of a surprise
because everybody thinks that 80 so
these excitatory neurons are really
doing the hard work the heavy lifting
they're the ones that are communicating
long distance and they're the ones that
are making decisions no
in this network it's the
relatively smaller subpopulation of
inhibitory neurons that are making the
decision
and and they're sending the troops off
to battle right the excitatory neurons
are getting their
their orders from the inhibitory neurons
this is this this tells us that these
inhibitory neurons might be actually uh
even more important than we imagined
now there are many types of inhibitory
neurons uh
and and we focus in on two of them
and and here's here's the premise the
premise is that we know that these delay
period activity neurons are found high
up in the hierarchy uh parietal cortex
and prefrontal cortex
and uh and are not found in early stages
of sensory processing in in the bottom
of the hierarchy and so the question is
if we look at the subpopulations of
inhibitory neurons and and the two we
focused on here were the par-valvulan
positive
basket cells providing the feedback
connections strong inhibitory feedback
to the pyramidal cells and the
somatostatin inhibitory neurons
that are primarily activating other
parts of the circuit and also
uh have strong inhibition onto the
parabelibumin iran so there's there's a
there's an additional complexity here
but the the but those populations have
been measured in a wide range of
cortical areas and they've been
put into a hierarchy here with uh
the early sensory areas in the
somatosensory the auditory individual
system on the right
and then high up in the prefrontal
cortex and the
infra temporal cortex here on the left
orbital frontal
and
infratemporals uh and insulin and so
and so if you look now at the parvel
human density
of inhibitory neurons which
and you know you can see here that uh
it's very high in the sensory areas the
early sensory processing areas but if
you go up to
the
prefrontal cortex
it drastically falls by a factor of five
and interestingly if you now
look at the plot of the
somatostatin
positive inhibitory interneurons
they are very low
in the pre in the early sensory
processing areas and they are very high
they they they were reciprocally
going up as the parallel b was going
down
and so this this really implicates these
neurons these could be the
subpopulations of the the somatostatin
neurons
would be a good place to look if you
wanted to see which sub-population is
responsible for making these decisions
and maintaining
delay period activity
okay well uh where does this take us uh
so what i've shown you one of many
examples now
in my lab and elsewhere of many groups
that have now applied these
machine learning techniques to create
networks and then to compare them
directly and quantitatively with neural
circuits
and also with
the firing patterns and and most notably
in the visual system there's a hierarchy
from the primary visual cortex at the
bottom up to infra-temporal cortex
through you know it does dozens there's
several dozen
critical areas in uh that are responsive
to different types of visual inputs in
this hierarchy and jim de carlo
amongst others has shown that if you
train up a deep learning network on
object recognition that the patterns of
firing of the neurons in different
levels of the hierarchy are very similar
to those that he records from monkey
visual cortex of these these different
levels
and
most recently he's shown that if you add
recurrent connections feedback
connections from a higher level to a
lower level or within layers which of
course we know is in the cortex
uh you can get even better
uh
comparisons and so this is this is great
because it's it's it's before we we kind
of suspected that the hierarchy has
something to do with perception of
objects but now i think we have much
more confidence because we can create a
network that actually has performance
that is comparable to that of humans in
terms of recognizing for example uh 10
000 different categories of objects
right
from millions of examples
and um and and so now we we we can
confirm that those uh
properties that we see in these
different cortical areas actually
have the
properties that you need in order to be
able to do object uh discrimination
and uh
if you're interested um
i told the story in a book i published
the deep learning revolution the story
here really goes back to huble and
weasel the uh network i just showed you
the convolutional neural network was
inspired by their recordings from visual
cortex and then by vanessa and others
who recorded in the higher visual areas
and then charlie rose who recorded up an
infant temporal cortex and so all of
that
went into
developing this new class of networks
called deep learning networks which have
had enormous success in artificial
intelligence
and now
as as those networks have been refined
and expanded and the latest versions now
that have been trained have uh have a
billion connections a billion weights
in them
which is you know
they're they're becoming not quite up to
the level of the cortex there's about a
a billion synapses in a cubic millimeter
of cortex so they're they're pretty far
away from
building a a real brain
but uh now
that they've been applied to
hundreds thousands of applications and
have had great success in in especially
in natural language processing language
translation um and and so now as we
understand more and more about these
networks as they become more
sophisticated for example the latest
generations have included attention
which has had a huge impact in
performance
and and as we have more
a bio-inspired uh
mechanisms
we see that the improvement performance
now can now be taken back and give us
insight into biological mechanisms and
this this reciprocal going back and
forth wasn't possible before traditional
ai which was based on logic and rules
but uh in my book you can see the
tagline artificial intelligence means
human intelligence and if you don't have
the time to read the book
uh there's a
a shorter highlight uh in a
paper i published last year in the
preceding national academy of sciences
on the unreasonable effectiveness of
deep learning artificial intelligence
which sort of gives us a guideline
into what to expect both in terms of the
past
and how we got here and also some really
exciting new mathematical advances that
have occurred by mathematicians
analyzing these networks telling us
you know mathematically why they behave
because otherwise it would be a paradox
okay so that's the end of my talk and i
want to give credit to robert kim
who was uh did this uh one of many
projects in my lab that was
really uh path breaking and uh then
thank you very much as the sun sets over
the pacific
i say you do